[Music]
the transformers franchise has long been
an integral part of movie theaters and
even the departure of some of its stars
in the past could not change that
following all the postponements of the
last few years the seventh part
transformers rise of the beast is no
longer far away so that we can slowly
but surely turn our attention to this
storyline the producers have come up
with something special for the new part
indeed the story deals with the early
animated series from the 80s and 90s
called beast wars in other words
alongside the autobots and decepticons
this time there are also the maximals
and the evil terracons we have taken a
look for you at what has changed in the
cast what the plot might be like and
what obstacles there are to overcome in
the production but enough talk let's get
started with our new original
before we get to the new movie let's
briefly recap what happened in the last
installment the new feature will be a
sequel to the 2018 movie bumblebee if
you haven't seen the movie yet and don't
want to be spoiled you better make sure
to skip to the next section now
bumblebee or
b127 hits the middle of a military
exercise during his escape from
cybertron to earth he's pursued by the
decepticon bullet wing not only is
bumblebee's voice system damaged in the
fight between the two but senior officer
burns is also seriously injured
bumblebee is found by charlie watson who
is given him as a gift transformed into
a yellow volkswagen beetle however when
she starts up the ottoman for the first
time it emits a signal that is picked up
by the decepticons the decepticons
shatter and drop cake land on earth but
are intercepted by the secret government
agency sector 7. they pose as
peacekeepers who are searching for the
criminal b127 a battle breaks out
between bumblebee the decepticons and
the military with a letter recognizing
all too late the real nature of the evil
robots in the end however bumblebee wins
with the help of charlie eventually the
autobots arrive on earth and optimus
prime expresses his gratitude to b127
for his assistance in charlie's voice he
answers that his name is bumblebee
since this is a new prequel the cast is
also almost entirely new unlike in the
previous films we will briefly summarize
the changes in the various groups so far
first we have anthony ramos who plays
the young noah he's a battle-hardened
veteran his main role is to take care of
his mother and his little brother and he
has to work a lot to provide them with a
modest life on the verge of poverty his
strength lies in handling electronic
devices which he enjoys using to repair
a variety of things in this regard his
mother will also have a part in the film
we don't know her name yet but she will
be embodied by lauren velez further we
have dominique fishback who will be
playing a young museum employee named
elena her job is far from ideal as she's
bullied by her boss both are likely to
be the human supporters for the autobots
more is not known on this side yet but
there will definitely be some more
people added surely from sector 7 as
well
as mentioned there are some new species
on the transformers side in the seventh
movie so let's have a look at both the
old and the new giants
optimus prime will of course once again
act as the leader of the autobots and
just like in the old parts he will be
dubbed by peter cullen naturally he will
again appear as the 1987 freightliner
fla semi truck also remaining unchanged
is bumblebee as a camaro the other
autobots are rc mirage and wheeljack we
have seen them before in transformers 2
and 3 with rc performing to transform
into a motorcycle wheeljack into a
mercedes and mirage into a ferrari 458
italia however in rise of the beast the
latter will get to transform into a blue
porsche 911 also mirage is partly
considered a sympathizer with the
decepticons which is certainly due to
his somewhat thuggish nature
for the first maximal we would like to
introduce you to their leader optimus
primal unlike the autobots or
decepticons the maximals transform into
mechanical animals optimus primal
transforms into a giant gorilla for
example he's voiced by sons of anarchy
star ron perlman primal was the head of
a research ship that went of course
while pursuing a predicament ship by the
way inside the predicament ship said
none other than megatron in terms of
character the steely gorilla is very
down to earth although he does love to
talk big of course this does not imply
that he is not ready to use any means to
cope with a dicey situation he is always
able of finding a solution no matter how
unusual it may be and him his friends
have a loyal partner and he even treats
his enemies with a fair amount of
respect his right hand man is rhinox he
transforms himself into
you guessed it a giant rhinoceros he has
a reputation for being calm and
level-headed and would certainly be
equally capable of leading the maximals
if he were not so respectful of optimus
he has also taken a maximal under his
wing much like optimus prime took
bumblebee the talk is of eraser who
transforms into a peregrine falcon and
thus forms the maximal's air force last
up we have cheetorukan turn into a
cheetah making him the perfect hunter on
land but enough of the good spirits
let's move on to the bad guys
the leader of the terracons is scorch he
is a decepticon who was assembled by
unicron from other dead decepticons and
he is going to be our new super villain
as mentioned in part 7 he is the leader
of the terror cons and incredibly
powerful much like optimus prime he
transforms into a truck that being a
peterbilt 359 logging semi truck his
henchmen are nightbird and battle trap
in the cartoons nightbird is a ninja
rubber created by humans which was then
stolen and improved by the decepticons
in the comics she is unable to transform
but they did change that for the movie
her form of appearance is a nissan
skyline gtr r33 in addition she will be
the hand woman of scourge in contrast
battle trap is more in charge when it
comes to the rough stuff you can also
tell that from his appearance as a 1980s
gmc top kick c7000 tow truck
not a lot is known about the plot yet
and it will probably stay that way up
until the first trailer so first let's
take a look at the confirmed locations
new york city or rather the borough of
brooklyn has been chosen as the main
setting of course once you hear 1994 and
brooklyn you can't help but think of the
prevailing hip-hop culture who knows
maybe there are even references to
actual greats of that time like the
notorious b.i.g or most death moreover
they also head to the southern
hemisphere peru to be exact there the
legendary inca town of machu picchu is
likely to be in particular spotlight and
we really hope that the century's old
wonder of the world won't suffer too
much damage we can safely assume that
there will be a hunt for an important
artifact in the old transformers style
which is meant to resurrect cybertron as
mentioned earlier the plot takes place
seven years after bumblebee which means
that the military will certainly not
have forgotten about the existence of
the machines yet while the classic
conflict is still between autobots and
decepticons the maximals and terracon
species will probably be dragged into
this war as well after all the maximals
are the descendants of the autobots
while the terracons are the descendants
of the decepticons nevertheless the
maximals do not have much in common with
their predecessors they strive for
tranquil life and harmony and are
actually no longer concerned with the
everlasting civil war the terror cons on
the other hand are just as dangerous and
evil as their predecessors besides they
are made of dark anogen and at least in
the first generation cartoons they are
also able to absorb anagen from other
transformers in order to become even
stronger another interesting question
will be whether megatron will be making
a comeback producer lorenzo di
buenaventura stated in an interview that
he felt the need for new villain which
is why scorch was brought in also we
keep reading the name of the predacons
likewise a race of transformers but one
that primarily transforms into
prehistoric life forms whether there
will be a connection to them in machu
picchu is something we will learn by the
release of the movie at the latest
okay so let's move on to our last topic
the production sitting in the director's
chair is no longer michael bay but
stephen cable jr the 34 year old has
already enjoyed some success with cree 2
and will now put his skills to the test
with the new transformers producer
lorenzo dibrano ventura who has been
involved in the franchise since the
beginning will provide assistance
joining him is former director michael
bay filming has been wrapped up since
october 21 2021 therefore we expect the
current release date of june 9th 2023 to
remain unchanged in the meantime another
transformers movie has been announced
for 2024 though this time it will be
computer animated instead of being a
live action film
and that was the latest information
about transformers rise of the beasts we
hope we were able to help you pass the
time until a first teaser trailer will
hopefully be released soon all that
remains now is the question of what
you're most looking forward to in the
new film we are for instance extremely
excited about the terracons and the
maximals let us know your thoughts in
the comments and if you liked this video
be sure to give it a thumbs up see you
next time
[Music]
you